This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the summer of 1776, 33-year-old Thomas Jefferson drafted one of the most important documents in the history of the United States. The Declaration of Independence laid out a vision for a new country and said all men had God-given rights to life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. 86 changes to the draft were made by John Adams, Ben Franklin, and others. Like many writers, Thomas Jefferson is said to have been unhappy with the changes his editors recommended. But the line about how we are all entitled to the pursuit of happiness endured.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。1776年夏天，33岁的托马斯·杰斐逊起草了美国历史上最重要的文件之一。《独立宣言》为新国家描绘了愿景，并宣告所有人享有上帝赋予的生命权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。生命权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。约翰·亚当斯、本·富兰克林等人对初稿进行了86处修改。和许多作家一样，据说托马斯·杰斐逊对他的编辑们建议的修改很不高兴。但关于我们都享有追求幸福权利的那一行保留了下来。
In recent years, many elements of the Declaration of happiness endured. In recent years, many elements of the Declaration of Independence have come under scrutiny, including its omission of women, the poor, and enslaved people from its vision of equality. We've examined some of these ideas in an earlier episode that looked at Thomas Jefferson's complicated life story. that looked at Thomas Jefferson's complicated life story. This week on Hidden Brain, we launched a new series we're calling Happiness 2.0. We start today by exploring Jefferson's psychological claim about what makes for a good life, with research that examines what happens in our minds when we pursue happiness, when you ask people what they want in life, nearly everyone will tell you they want to be happy. After all, that's the point of finding a great job, starting a family, or going on wonderful
近年来，人们对《独立宣言》的许多要素进行了审查，包括其愿景中的平等漏掉了妇女、穷人和被奴役者。我们在早期的一期节目中探讨过其中的一些观点，那期节目回顾了托马斯·杰斐逊复杂的人生故事。回顾了托马斯·杰斐逊复杂的人生故事。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们推出一个名为“幸福2.0”的新系列。我们今天从探讨杰斐逊关于美好生活构成要素的心理学主张开始，通过研究来探讨当我们在追求幸福时，我们的大脑会发生什么，当你问人们他们在生活中想要什么时，几乎所有人都会告诉你他们想快乐。毕竟，这正是寻找好工作、组建家庭或进行美好
vacations. At the University of California Berkeley, psychologists Iris Maas studies a paradox associated with our pursuit of happiness. Iris Maas, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Iris, about a decade ago, you achieved a major milestone in the life of a scholar. You got 10 years at a great university. How long of a scholar. You got tenure at a great university. How long had you dreamed of becoming a professor at a school like UC Berkeley? I think forever. So this was a really big deal for me.
度假的意义所在。在加州大学伯克利分校，心理学家爱丽丝·马斯研究了与我们追求幸福相关的悖论。爱丽丝·马斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。爱丽丝，大约十年前，你在学者生涯中取得了一个重要的里程碑。你在一家伟大的大学获得了10年教龄。作为一个学者，你在一家伟大的大学获得了终身教职有多长时间了？你梦想成为像加州大学伯克利分校这样的学校的教授有多久了？我想是一直以来。所以这对我和我来说真的是一件大事。
I'd been working toward this for a long time and had been really looking forward to that moment, hoping I would get tenure. Getting tenure is a big deal of course. I would get to be with the most lovely colleagues I could imagine and doing what I love in a beautiful area. Now, whenever I visit UC Berkeley, I'm struck by how beautiful it is. I mean, Berkeley really is absolutely gorgeous. So, mission accomplished, Iris? Well, not quite. It wasn't quite the way that I had imagined. It's sort of like the thing wherever you go, there you are.
我为之努力了很长时间，并且真的很期待那一刻，希望我能获得终身教职。获得终身教职当然是一件大事。我将能和我想象中最可爱的同事在一起，并在一个美丽的地区做我热爱的事情。现在，每当我访问加州大学伯克利分校时，我都为它的美丽所震撼。我的意思是，伯克利真的是绝对的美丽。所以，任务完成了，爱丽丝？嗯，不完全是。它并不完全是我想象的那样。这有点像无论你走到哪里，你就在那里的那种感觉。
So, I was still the same person somehow and worries and stressful things still happen. Although at first, at least in the sort of year after getting tenure, those sort of small worries hit me almost more than before because they have this element of, wait a minute, shouldn't I be happy all the time? Is there something wrong with me that I have 10 years now? And yet, I still have worries in my life. I understand you had a similar experience
所以，某种程度上我还是同一个人，烦恼和压力重重的事情仍然会发生。虽然一开始，至少在获得终身教职后的那一年左右，那些小烦恼几乎比以前更深地击中了我，因为它们带有这种元素：等一下，难道我不应该一直都很快乐吗？我既然现在有了终身教职，是不是有什么不对劲？然而，我的生活中依然有烦恼。我听说你也有过类似的经历
more recently, Iris, when you took a trip to the Italian island of Sardinia, what was your state of anticipation before the trip? This was the first trip I took in a really long time and I was going to get together with my very oldest childhood friend, she lives in Germany, I hadn't seen her in two years and we had this trip planned and I thought this is just gonna be Amazing. I'm gonna be relaxing. I'm gonna be happy. I Visualized it almost like one of those Tuscan Italian movies, you know, we would be on the beach
更近一些时候，爱丽丝，当你去意大利萨丁尼亚岛旅行时，你对这次旅行的期待状态是什么？这是我很久以来第一次旅行，我要去和我最老童年朋友相聚，她住在德国，我已经两年没见她了，我们计划了这次旅行，我想这一定会是惊人的。我会放松的。我会开心的。我把它想象得几乎就像那些托斯卡纳意大利电影一样，你知道的，我们会在海滩上
We would be drinking wine in movies, you know, we would be on the beach, we would be drinking wine, eating delicious food, we would go boating around the little island and just floating happily in those beautiful turquoise waters. So I had every expectation and so much anticipation that it would be just the perfect participation that it would be just the perfect 10 days. So what happened Iris? Well, we had a lovely time, but little thoughts or moments snuck in where I would be thinking about work or I would worry about something going on at home. So these little thoughts started to appear and I would think, wait a minute, this isn't right, this isn't supposed to be here this thought. What's going on? Have I lost the ability to relax? Is there something wrong with me? Is there something wrong with the vacation?
我们在电影里喝着酒，你知道的，我们会去海滩，我们会喝着酒，吃着美味的食物，我们会坐船绕着小岛游玩，高兴地漂浮在那些美丽的绿松石般的水面上。所以我满怀期望，充满期待，这将会是完美的10天，充满期待，这将会是完美的10天。那么发生了什么，爱丽丝？嗯，我们度过了一段美好的时光，但是一些小想法或小瞬间溜了进来，我会想到工作，或者我会担心家里发生的事情。所以这些小想法开始出现，我会想，等一下，这不对，这个想法不应该在这里。怎么回事？我失去放松的能力了吗？我有什么毛病吗？是假期有什么不对吗？
Why am I not happy every moment of every day? So you're on the strip with your childhood friend and her partner. Did your restlessness affect your travel companions, too? I think I maybe I drove on a tiny little nutty because I started to suggest sort of all kinds of things to bring about the continuous happy state that I had anticipated. So I would say, let's go to this other beach today or let's rent a boat and go around this little island or let's go to a different restaurant and Maybe that was a little bit much for them. I have a colleague who describes vacations like this as March or Die
为什么我不能在每天的每分每秒都快乐呢？所以你和你的童年朋友以及她的伴侣在这次旅行中。你的焦躁不安也影响了你的旅伴吗？我想我可能把他们弄得有点小疯，因为我开始建议各种各样的事情来维持我所期待的持续快乐状态。所以我会说，我们今天去另一个海滩吧，或者我们租艘船绕这个小岛转转吧，或者我们去一家不同的餐厅吧，也许这对外他们来说有点太多了。我有一个同事把这样的假期形容为“行军或死亡”
There's no sitting in one place you either either march or you die. A little bit like that. I want to ask you about another episode in your life, Iris, and I think this one reveals how our approach to pursuing happiness is something we do not only for ourselves, but something we encourage in other people, including our kids. Back home in the Bay Area, you got busy throwing a party for your son's eighth birthday. What were the preparations for the party like? I mean I always tried to make his birthday parties really nice but this one in particular I
没有坐在同一个地方的说法，要么你行军，要么你死亡。有点像那样。我想问你生活中另一个插曲，爱丽丝，我认为这个插曲揭示了我们追求幸福的方法不仅是我们为自己做的事情，也是我们鼓励其他人（包括我们的孩子）去做的事情。回到湾区，你忙着为你儿子的八岁生日办派对。派对的筹备工作是怎样的？我的意思是，我总是尽力把他生日派对办得很好，但这次特别
wanted it to be perfect and so I had reserved a picnic spot at the local park. I got a coronavirus pinnata or you sort of bash a pinnata that looks like a coronavirus filled it with candy lots of games that I had thought of and decorations of course my friend who's an amazing baker, made this enormous stunning cake. And of course we had pizza. And when you visualize what this party would be like, I'm imagining you saw your son just basically being ecstatic the whole time and frolicking and playing with his friends. That's exactly right. Extatic the whole time, frallicking, based in golden rays of sunlight, exactly like that. So I almost hesitate to ask you the question, given the pattern that we're starting to see here, Iris.
我希望它是完美的，所以我预订了当地公园的一个野餐点。我买了一个冠状病毒皮纳塔，就是那种你敲打的、看起来像冠状病毒的皮纳塔，里面塞满了糖果，还有我想象的很多游戏，当然还有装饰品。我的朋友是一位出色的蛋糕师，她做了一个巨大而惊艳的蛋糕。当然我们还有披萨。当你想象这个派对会是什么样时，我猜你想象你的儿子基本上会一直欣喜若狂，欢快地和朋友们玩耍。完全正确。一直欣喜若狂，欢快地嬉戏，沐浴在金色的阳光中，完全是那样。所以鉴于我们在这里开始看到的模式，我几乎犹豫着要不要问你这个问题，爱丽丝。
But how did the party turn out when you arrived on the big day? Well, the first thing that happened was that this is in June, and it never rains in the Bay Area in June, never except that one day. And it was raining the morning of the party. So we had to sort of switch gears, like sort of text that everybody come a little later, hoping crossing my fingers, it would stop raining. We still went to the park to set up because my son was very impatient
但是当你在大日子到达时，派对结果如何？嗯，发生的第一件事是，这是在六月，而湾区六月从不下雨，绝不，除了那一天。派对那天早上下雨了。所以我们不得不改变计划，比如发短信让大家晚点来，希望、交叉手指，雨会停。我们还是去了公园布置，因为我儿子很不耐烦
and intent on having his party. So we go in the rain, we're setting everything up, we're getting drenched. And of course, people, I told them to come a little later, but my son had the start time of the party in his head, 11 o'clock. And 11 o'clock comes, in his head, 11 o'clock, and 11 o'clock comes. Nobody is there yet, and he starts to lose it. And I still sort of have that image in my head of him sort of standing in the rain, getting drenched, falling. And you must have felt like your heartburns breaking
一心想办他的派对。所以我们在雨中前去，我们把所有东西都布置好，我们全身湿透了。当然，人们，我告诉他们晚点来，但我儿子心里记着派对的开始时间，11点。11点到了，他心里想着11点，而11点到了。还没有人来，他开始崩溃了。我的脑海里依然浮现出他站在雨中，全身湿透、倒下的画面。你一定觉得心碎
because you had put so much time and effort and thought into making this the perfect party. Yeah, I was really upset, but it did stop raining and we went ahead and other things went wrong, of course. the pinata, you know, had gotten drenched in rain. And so when the pinata bashings was supposed to happen, it took just one swing and the whole thing just sort of sadly flopped down. And kids, they didn't want to play the games that I had planned for them. They did their own thing and it was a big disappointment and should have like bordering on disaster. When my son was bawling, standing in the rain, I thought, wow, this is actually the worst
因为你投入了大量的时间、精力和心思来把它办成一个完美的派对。是的，我真的很沮丧，但雨确实停了，我们继续进行了，当然其他事情也出了差错。皮纳塔，你知道的，已经被雨淋湿了。所以当本该进行皮纳塔敲击时，只用了一棍，整个东西就悲伤地瘫软下来。孩子们不想玩我为他们计划的游戏。他们做他们自己的事，这是一个巨大的失望，简直可以说是灾难边缘。当我儿子在雨中放声大哭时，我想，哇，这真的是最糟糕的
birthday party ever. What Iris did is something we all do. We dream about what it would feel like to accomplish something, to get something, or to be somewhere. We imagine how it would feel if we got into a great school, or found a great job, or fed in love with a perfect person who loved us back. Sometimes when those dreams don't work out, we are heartbroken. But even when they do work out, we often feel let down, cheated.
有史以来最糟糕的生日派对。爱丽丝所做的正是我们所有人都在做的事。我们梦想着完成某事、得到某物或身处某地会是什么感觉。我们想象着如果我们进入一所好学校、找到一份好工作，或者和一个深爱我们的完美人坠入爱河，会有什么感觉。有时当这些梦想没有实现时，我们会心碎。但即使它们实现了，我们常常也感到失望、被欺骗。
We achieve this difficult thing, obtain this amazing relationship, accomplished our dreams, why we find ourselves asking, are we not happier? When we come back, the problem with our theory of happiness. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Iris Mars has first-hand experience about what it feels like to chase a dream, only to feel let down when she obtained it. In her research as a psychologist at UC Berkeley, she has run a number of experiments to try to understand the phenomenon.
我们实现了这件困难的事，得到了这段美妙的关系，完成了我们的梦想，我们发现自己在问，为什么我们没有更快乐？当我们回来时，谈谈我们幸福理论的问题。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。爱丽丝·马斯对追逐梦想却在获得时感到失望的感受有着亲身体验。作为加州大学伯克利分校的一名心理学家，她在研究中做了一系列实验来试图理解这种现象。
Iris, lots of our listeners are people who are used to working hard to accomplish difficult things. If happiness is the most important goal of all, we tell ourselves, okay, let's work at it, let's accomplish it. You've studied people who chase after happiness in this way. What do studies reveal about their mental health and well-being? We found that people who are very intent on being happy, those same people somewhat ironically,
爱丽丝，我们的许多听众都是习惯于努力工作以完成困难任务的人。如果幸福是最重要的目标，我们告诉自己，好吧，让我们为之努力，让我们实现它。你研究过以这种方式追求幸福的人。研究揭示了他们的心理健康和福祉如何？我们发现，那些非常执着于快乐的人，这些人有些讽刺的是，
in general, have lower levels of well-being, higher levels of depressive symptoms, and paradoxically lower levels of overall happiness. So it seems that the more, perhaps, the more intent they are on being happy, the less they actually manage to be happy. So your research has identified several reasons for this. One has to do with the effects of high expectations. And perhaps we've heard some echoes of this in the stories you told us about becoming a tenured professor at UC Berkeley or the vacation in Italy. What is the role of high expectations in shaping our experience of happiness, Iris?
总的来说，他们的福祉水平较低，抑郁症状水平较高，而且自相矛盾的是，整体幸福感水平较低。所以似乎他们对快乐的执着可能越多，他们实际设法获得快乐的程度就越低。所以你的研究已经确定了几个原因。其中一个与高期望的影响有关。也许我们在你讲述的关于成为加州大学伯克利分校终身教授或去意大利度假的故事中听到了这方面的回响。高期望在塑造我们对幸福的体验中扮演什么角色，爱丽丝？
High expectations in other life domains can be a good thing, right? We might strive toward doing really well in school and then we work hard toward getting a good grade. We might fall short of it, feel disappointed, and that might motivate us to work harder. But in the domain of happiness, there's sort of a paradox there, right?
在其他生活领域，高期望可能是一件好事，对吧？我们可能会努力在学校做得很好，然后我们为获得好成绩而努力工作。我们可能达不到要求，感到失望，这可能会激励我们更加努力。但在幸福的领域，那里存在着某种悖论，对吧？
In that if we're disappointed when falling short of our goal that we're striving for, the high standard, that disappointment in itself contradicts the very goal. So the more we strive toward the goal of happiness, the more we undermine our ability to actually get there. And of course, once you actually get there, even if the experience is very good but not perfect, it might still fall short of the very high expectations we had. Yeah, that's exactly right.
如果我们对未能达到我们正在努力的目标、未能达到高标准感到失望，这种失望本身就与目标本身相矛盾。所以我们越是朝着幸福的目标努力，我们就越是削弱了我们实际到达那里的能力。当然，一旦你真正到达那里，即使体验非常好但并不完美，它可能仍然达不到我们所拥有的极高期望。是的，完全正确。
So you've cited a study carried out by the psychologist Jonathan Schuhler and his colleagues. They studied people getting ready to celebrate the start of a new year. Tell me what the study found Iris. Yeah, so this was actually for New Year's Eve 2000, so it was a particularly big one. And a lot of people had really high expectations for what the big millennial New Year's Eve celebration would bring. And they asked people ahead of time how happy they expected to be and how much time they spend planning for the New disappointed with the celebration. And then the second really interesting thing that they found is that the more enjoyment participants expected having the more disappointed they actually ended up being. So it's not like greater expectation and working
所以你引用了心理学家乔纳森·舒勒（Jonathan Schooler）及其同事开展的一项研究。他们研究了准备庆祝新年到来的人们。请告诉我这项研究发现了什么，爱丽丝。是的，这实际上是针对2000年跨年夜的，所以这是一个特别大的跨年。许多人对千禧年跨年庆祝活动会带来什么有着非常高的期望。他们提前询问人们他们期望自己有多快乐，以及他们花了多少时间为这个重大的庆祝活动做准备。他们发现的第一件事是，期望越高的人往往对庆祝活动越失望。然后他们发现的第二个非常有趣的事情是，参与者期望得到的乐趣越多，他们最终实际上感到的失望就越大。所以这并不像更高的期望和更多地
more toward enjoying the party would pay off with greater enjoyment. Actually the exact opposite happened. More expectation less enjoyment. I'm assuming this means that people who plan bigger parties might paradoxically have been less happy than people with smaller gatherings. That's exactly what they found. There's another reason that chasing happiness can have the inadvertent effect of chasing it away. What is the effect of checking to see if we are happy on our experience of happiness. Checking how happy we are is very much so bound up with thinking that happiness is an important thing. And it's also something that we do, I think, very automatically. In all of the examples, I think, that I gave from my own life, it's very much so that the moment I checked in on
为享受派对而努力会带来更大的乐趣作为回报。实际上，恰恰相反的情况发生了。期望越高，乐趣越少。我假设这意味着筹办更大派对的人，自相矛盾地，可能比聚会规模较小的人更不快乐。这正是他们发现的。追逐幸福会产生适得其反、将其赶跑的效果，还有另一个原因。检查我们是否快乐对我们的幸福体验有什么影响。检查我们有多快乐，很大程度上与认为快乐是一件重要的事情交织在一起。这也是我们做得非常自动的一件事，我认为。在我自己生活的所有例子中，我认为，非常明显的是，当我检查
how happy am I, how is this going, that's when I realized, oh actually I'm not quite as happy as I hope to be. And various studies allude to that, or have examined that relationship between what's called experience, hedonic experiences, and metaconsciousness. So that sort of overlay of being self-consciously aware of how we're feeling. One domain of research where this has been examined is in the research of flow. And this is researched by Mihali Txik Santi Mali.
我有多快乐，这一切进展如何的那一刻，我才意识到，哦，实际上我并没有我希望的那样快乐。各种研究都暗示了这一点，或者研究了所谓体验、享乐体验（hedonic experiences）与元意识（metaconsciousness）之间的这种关系。也就是那种对我们自己的感觉有着自我意识的觉察的叠加。研究这方面的一个领域是关于心流（flow）的研究。这是米哈里·契克森米哈赖（Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi）的研究。
He and colleagues have shown that when people are in a state of flow, they report later on being incredibly happy. So it's a state of deep happiness, but what's important is that it's also characterized by being completely unaware of the self. So it means that the self almost feels like it's dissolved during these states of flow, and in fact it's interrupted and destroyed when you check in with yourself and ask, how am I feeling now? You know, I'm reminded of something that the 19th century philosopher John Stuart Mill once noticed, he said, ask yourself whether you are happy and you cease to be so. And that's saying exactly what you are suggesting, Iris, which is that the act of turning that
他和同事们已经表明，当人们处于心流状态时，他们事后报告说自己非常快乐。所以这是一种深度的快乐，但重要的是，它的特征也是完全对自我无意识。这意味着在这些心流状态下，自我几乎感觉像溶解了一样，事实上，当你向内审视自己并问“我现在感觉如何？”时，它就会被打断和破坏。你知道，我想起了19世纪哲学家约翰·斯图亚特·密尔（John Stuart Mill）曾经注意到的一句话，他说，问问自己是否快乐，你就停止快乐了。这说的正是你所建议的，爱丽丝，也就是说，将那个
spotlight inward and asking, am I happy? Even when you are happy, it tends to have the effect of diminishing the experience of happiness. Yes, so those ideas have been around for a long time. John Stuart Mill thought about hedonic experiences, of course, a lot. And there's another quote that I really like and that gets to the heart of another problem with striving too much to be happy.
聚光灯向内转并问“我快乐吗？”这一行为，即使在你快乐的时候，往往也会产生削弱幸福体验的效果。是的，所以这些想法已经存在很长时间了。约翰·斯图亚特·密尔当然对享乐体验思考了很多。还有另一句我非常喜欢的名言，它触及了过度努力追求快乐的另一个问题的核心。
And he said, those only are happy who have their minds fixed on some object other than their own happiness. On the happiness of others, on the improvement of mankind, even on some art or pursuit, followed not as a means, but as itself and ideal end. Aiming does it something else, they find happiness by the way. And I really like that quote because it gets at another problem with overvaluing happiness or valuing it in the wrong way. And that's the idea that if we strive for our own happiness at the expense of what's going on around us, that's when things can go wrong and backfire.
他说，只有那些心智专注于除自身幸福之外的某种对象的人才是快乐的。专注于他人的幸福、人类的进步，甚至专注于某种艺术或追求，不是作为一种手段，而是作为其自身和理想的目标。将目标对准其他事物，他们在顺便找到了快乐。我真的很喜欢这句名言，因为它触及了过度重视幸福或以错误方式重视幸福的另一个问题。这就是这种观点：如果我们以牺牲周围发生的事情为代价来争取我们自己的幸福，那正是事情可能出错并适得其反的时候。
In many ways Iris does get to another idea I wanted to talk with you about, which is, is it possible that one reason pursuing happiness is an ineffective strategy is that we often don't know what it is that's going to make us happy. And so by pursuing things that we think will make us happy, we sometimes take our eye off the ball of the things that actually will make us happy. I think that's really right. Dan Gilbert and others have found that humans are actually pretty lousy at knowing what will make them happy. And one of the things that makes people most happy is spending time with others and being connected and close to other people. And sort of this overly intense pursuit of one's own happiness,
在许多方面，爱丽丝确实切入了我想与你讨论的另一个想法，那就是，追求幸福是一种无效策略的一个原因，是否可能是因为我们常常不知道到底是什么能让我们快乐。因此，通过追求我们认为会让我们快乐的事物，我们有时会把视线从真正能让我们快乐的事物上移开。我认为这非常正确。丹·吉尔伯特（Dan Gilbert）和其他人发现，人类其实很不擅长知道什么能让自己快乐。而让人最快乐的事情之一就是与他人共度时光，与其他人建立联系和亲密关系。而这种对个人幸福的过度强烈追求，
that can come at the expense of connecting with other people. We did a study that gets at that question asking whether if we don't pursue happiness in a way that sacrifices connection with other people, maybe we can get around the paradoxical effects of overvaluing happiness. And we took advantage of the fact that cultures differ with respect to what happiness tends to mean to people. And we sample participants from cultures that are more socially oriented, East Asian cultures, Japan and Taiwan,
可能会以牺牲与他人的联系为代价。我们做了一项研究，切入了那个问题，询问如果我们不以牺牲与他人联系的方式追求幸福，我们是否能够绕过过度重视幸福的悖论效应。我们利用了这样一个事实：不同文化在幸福对人们倾向于意味着什么方面有所不同。我们从更具社会导向的文化（东亚文化、日本和台湾）
all the way to cultures that tend to be more individualistically oriented, less socially oriented, the US. And then we had two cultures in between Russia and Germany. And in each of those samples, we as participants, how much they valued happiness, but also what happiness means to them. And then we looked at their overall levels of well-being. And what we found was really interesting because it suggests a way to get around that paradox that we've been talking about. So in the US, we found that valuing happiness was very much bound up with a more individualistic, less social pursuit of happiness.
一直采样到倾向于更加个人主义导向、较少社会导向的文化（美国）。然后我们在中间有两种文化：俄罗斯和德国。在每一个样本中，我们询问参与者他们有多重视幸福，以及幸福对他们意味着什么。然后我们研究了他们整体的福祉水平。我们发现的结果非常有趣，因为它暗示了一种绕过我们一直在讨论的悖论的方法。在美国，我们发现重视幸福很大程度上与更个人主义、较少社会的幸福追求交织在一起。
And here we found that exact link that we've been talking about, the more people valued happiness, the less happy they were. But then as we went in the social direction on that gradient, to Germany, to Russia, to East Asia, we found that pursuit of happiness was more and more connected with helping other people and being close with other people. So what we found is that the more socially people interpret the value of happiness, the more that valuing happiness was associated with higher levels of well-being. So we've looked at several ways in which pursuing happiness in a very individualistic fashion can paradoxically make us less happy.
在这里，我们发现了我们一直在讨论的那种确切联系：人们越重视幸福，他们就越不幸福。但随着我们沿着那个梯度朝着社会的、集体的方向发展，到德国、到俄罗斯、到东亚，我们发现对幸福的追求越来越多地与帮助他人和与他人亲近联系在一起。所以我们发现，人们对幸福价值的社会化解释越多，重视幸福就越与更高的福祉水平相关。所以我们研究了几种以非常个人主义的方式追求幸福会自相矛盾地让我们不那么快乐的方式。
It ramps up our expectations, which diminishes our satisfaction. It causes us to ask ourselves if we are happy, which is often not a good way to actually experience happiness. And it makes it more likely that we will turn away from others and experience loneliness. I want to talk about one of the really important idea, Iris. Besides chasing happiness, many of us also spend a great deal of time trying to escape unhappiness. I want to take you back to your days as a graduate student and have you tell us about the negative emotions you experienced whenever you had to make public presentations about
它提高了我们的期望，从而减少了我们的满足感。它促使我们问自己是否快乐，而这通常不是真正体验快乐的好方法。它使得我们更可能背离他人并体验孤独。我想谈谈一个非常重要的想法，爱丽丝。除了追逐幸福，我们许多人还花费大量时间试图逃避不快乐。我想带你回到你作为研究生的日子，让你告诉我们，每当你不得不做关于你的工作的公开演讲时，你所经历的负面情绪。
your work. So like many people, I used to have anxiety about speaking in front of audiences. And as a psychology graduate student, when I first started to have to give research presentations, this anxiety was actually pretty intense, almost overwhelming at the time. And I remember particularly clearly, I think this was the first talk I had to give as a graduate student to faculty and other students in the area I was part of. So maybe a group of 30 people. So for weeks before that talk and any talk, So for weeks before that talk and any talk, I would have all these worries circling through my head about all the incredibly foolish things I would definitely
所以和许多人一样，我过去对在观众面前发言感到焦虑。作为一名心理学研究生，当我第一次开始不得不做研究报告时，这种焦虑其实相当强烈，当时几乎让人不知所措。我记得特别清楚，我想这是我作为研究生必须对我们所在领域的教职员工和其他学生做的第一次演讲。所以可能是一个大约30人的小组。所以在该演讲和任何演讲之前的数周内，
say, but how I would freeze, sinking feeling of doom really, and lots of sleepless nights, which doesn't particularly help. So my approach was to think, well, wait a minute, I need to get rid of this anxiety, telling myself, it's just a speech, come on, get it together, try to ignore it, but, and I think this is pretty common, the anxiety would always return. And maybe even stronger than before, because it would then return along with the feeling that it confirms
在我的脑海里盘旋着所有那些我肯定会说的令人难以置信的愚蠢事情的担忧，以及我会如何僵住、真正陷入厄运的下沉感，还有许多不眠之夜，这并没有特别的帮助。所以我的方法是想，好吧，等一下，我需要摆脱这种焦虑，告诉自己，这只是一场演讲，得了吧，振作起来，试着忽略它，但是，我认为这很常见，焦虑总是会卷土重来。而且可能比以前更强烈，因为它随后会伴随着一种感觉卷土重来，即它证实了
there's something wrong about me. And this is so revealing, Iris, because what was happening here was not just that you were distressed, but that you were distressed about being distressed. Yes, so these were what's called negative meta-emotion. So feelings about my feelings, and those were almost worse, maybe than the initial round of feelings, because there's a saying that goes, pain is inevitable, but suffering is optional. And these meta emotions, that's the suffering that we layer on top of negative emotions. I was wondering, did these concerns
我身上确实有些毛病。这太具有启发性了，爱丽丝，因为这里发生的事情不仅是你感到痛苦，而是你对自己的痛苦感到痛苦。是的，所以这些就是所谓的负面元情绪（negative meta-emotion）。也就是对我的感觉的感觉，这些几乎比最初的一轮感觉更糟糕，因为有一句俗语说，痛苦是不可避免的，但受苦是可选的。而这些元情绪，就是我们在负面情绪之上层层叠加的痛苦。我想知道，这些担忧
and I guess these concerns about these concerns, were they serious enough that you started to think that maybe you were not cut out for this kind of career? Yeah, absolutely. Because giving research presentations is a really big part of the job. And so it just became so bad that I consider dropping out of grad school.
我想这些对这些担忧的担忧，是否严重到让你开始认为自己或许不适合这种职业？是的，绝对有。因为做研究报告是这份工作非常重要的一部分。所以情况变得如此糟糕，以至于我考虑过从研究生院退学。
One of the things you just told me you did when you had these negative thoughts was to try and find ways to suppress them, to make them go away. And I think many of us do this. You've reviewed research that finds that ignoring or pushing away negative feelings can negatively affect how we relate to other people.
你刚才告诉我，当你有这些负面想法时，你所做的事情之一就是试图找到方法来压制它们，让它们消失。我想我们很多人都这样做过。你回顾过研究发现，忽视或推开负面情绪会对我们与他人的关系产生负面影响。
Tell me about this research, Iris. Yeah, there's quite a bit of research on this, how suppressing our own emotions can be bad for ourselves, but also especially bad for interpersonal contexts. So in a recent study, we brought dating couples into the lab, and we had them carry out two conversations. The first one, we wanted them to talk about something that is a problem in the relationship. So things like how often do you visit each other's families, disagreements about finances, disagreements about housework.
请告诉我这项研究，爱丽丝。是的，关于这方面的研究相当多，关于压制我们自己的情绪如何对我们自己不好，而且对人际交往环境尤其不好。所以在最近的一项研究中，我们将约会伴侣带进实验室，让他们进行两次对话。第一次，我们希望他们谈论关系中存在的问题。比如你们多久拜访一次对方的家庭、对财务的分歧、对家务的分歧。
And so the couples had basically a fight in the lab. And then we had them carry out a positive conversation where we told them to tell each other how much they appreciated one another and what they loved about one another and those were lovely conversations. Now, after each conversation, we asked them how much they had suppressed their feelings while they had talked with their romantic partner. And we also asked them how well they thought the conversation went and how connected they felt to one another. And what we found is that no matter whether we were looking at a fight or at the loving
所以这些伴侣基本上在实验室里吵了一架。然后我们让他们进行一次积极的对话，我们告诉他们互相告诉对方他们有多感激彼此，他们有多爱彼此，那些都是很棒的对话。现在，在每次对话之后，我们询问他们在与浪漫伴侣交谈时压抑了多少自己的感情。我们还询问他们认为对话进行得有多好，以及他们觉得自己与彼此的联系有多紧密。我们发现的是，无论我们看的是争吵还是充满爱意的
conversations, when people said that they had suppressed their emotions, and that was true for positive and for negative emotions, the more they suppressed them, the less they shared them with their partner, the less well the conversations went, and the less connected they fell to one another. So that suggests that holding back emotions, even if it's negative emotions, seems to disturb social connection. As we've heard, chasing happiness in a highly individualistic manner does not work. Trying to elude unhappiness doesn't work either. When we come back, what does work? You're listening to Hidden Brain.
对话，当人们说他们压抑了自己的情绪时，这对于积极和消极情绪都是如此，他们压抑得越多，他们与伴侣分享得就越少，对话进行得就越糟糕，他们觉得自己与彼此的联系也就越少。这表明克制情绪，即使是负面情绪，似乎也会扰乱社会联系。正如我们所听到的，以高度个人主义的方式追逐幸福是行不通的。试图躲避不快乐也是行不通的。当我们回来时，什么才管用？您正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. The conventional way most of us go about accomplishing anything is to work hard at it. When it comes to happiness, many of us say, if this is something I really want, I need to go out and get it. This might be especially true in the United States, where the Declaration of Independence celebrates the pursuit of happiness. The problem is, pursuing happiness can have the paradoxical effect of chasing happiness away. Trying to elude unhappiness can be similarly counterproductive. unhappiness can be similarly counterproductive.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们大多数人完成任何事情的传统方式是努力工作。谈到幸福时，我们许多人说，如果这是我真正想要的东西，我需要走出去把它争取来。在美国尤其如此，那里的《独立宣言》颂扬了对幸福的追求。问题是，追求幸福会产生把幸福赶跑的悖论效果。试图躲避不快乐同样会适得其反。试图躲避不快乐同样会适得其反。
Psychologist Iris Maas has spent many years asking herself what does work when it comes to living a happier life. A crucial moment of insight came from her own life. Yeah, so when my son was really little, baby, I'd say between six months and maybe it went all the way till three years. He would have what is sometimes called witching hour which is exactly what it sounds like. It's long hours of crying and fussiness and so he would cry. It's time to go to sleep, I needed to rest. I would rock him back to sleep and really, really gingerly put him in his crib and he would instantly wake back up and it would start over. Repeating itself up to like two hours, maybe even more at a time. And I remember being really distressed about it just because it's exhausting and pleasant, but really thinking,
心理学家爱丽丝·马斯花了很多年问自己，在过上更幸福的生活方面，什么才是真正管用的。一个至关重要的洞察时刻来自她自己的生活。是的，所以当我儿子还很小的时候，是个婴儿，我想在六个月到大概三岁之间。他会有有时被称为“巫婆时刻”（witching hour）的时刻，这完全和听起来一样。那是长时间的哭泣和烦躁，所以他会哭。该睡觉了，我需要休息。我会把他摇晃哄睡，非常非常小心翼翼地把他放进婴儿床，他会立刻醒来，一切又重新开始。重复长达两个小时，甚至一次更久。我记得对此感到非常痛苦，仅仅是因为这既筋疲力尽又不愉快，而且真的在想，
here's my poor baby, he ought to sleep peacefully. What am I doing wrong? So just asking, what's wrong with me, what's wrong with him? Why can't I get him to be peaceful, comforted? Why isn't he happy? And really, the more frantically I'm trying to comfort him, the more upset he and I would become sort of like a vicious cycle really. So there came a moment when you changed your approach to his distress. Tell me what happened, Iris.
这是我可怜的宝宝，他本该安详地睡觉。我做错了什么？所以只是在问，我有什么毛病，他有什么毛病？为什么我不能让他平静、得到安慰？为什么他还不开心？真的，我越是狂热地试图安慰他，他和我的情绪就会变得越沮丧，这真的是一个恶性循环。所以有一个时刻，你改变了对待他痛苦的方式。告诉我发生了什么，爱丽丝。
Yeah, so it kind of came to a head because I read one too many sleep advice books. You know, they all tell different advice. Keep a schedule, go with a flow, hold the baby, rock the baby, bounce the baby, blow a hair dryer on the baby, keep it quiet, get the baby used to the noise. That kind of thing and as a new parent it really can drive you a little nutty. I think it just came to a point where I was reading all that and I'm like, I can't do this. And I realized in a way, it was really not in my control because trying all these things hadn't yielded the expected hope for effects.
是的，这有点达到了一个顶峰，因为我读了太多本睡眠建议的书。你知道的，它们都给出不同的建议。保持规律作息、顺其自然、抱着婴儿、摇晃婴儿、颠着婴儿、对婴儿吹电吹风、保持安静、让婴儿习惯噪音。诸如此类的事情，作为一个新手父母，这真的会把你弄得有点发疯。我想它只是到了一个地步，我读了所有这些，然后我想：我做不到。我意识到在某种程度上，这真的不在我的控制之中，因为尝试所有这些并没有产生预期的、希望的效果。
So in a way, I hit a wall and I had to accept what was. What did you do differently once you had this realization? I didn't do anything differently, but my perspective on it changed. differently, but my perspective on it changed. And I let go of the ought to control it, he ought to be peaceful, he ought to go to sleep, he ought to be happy. And that perspective change was almost like a little magic because the moment I changed my perspective, that very moment, a lot of the tension just left. He still cried, so it didn't change anything about the crying per se, but the moments or the times of crying almost became pleasant. I mean, it's weird to say that,
所以在某种程度上，我撞墙了，我不得不接受现状。当你有了这种认识后，你有什么不同的做法吗？我没有做任何不同的事，但我对它的观点改变了。没有做任何不同的事，但我对它的观点改变了。我放下了“应该”控制它的想法：他“应该”平静，他“应该”去睡觉，他“应该”快乐。而这种观点的改变几乎就像一个小小的魔术，因为当我改变观点的那一刻，就在那一刻，很多紧张感一下子消失了。他还是哭了，所以它本身并没有改变哭泣的任何事情，但哭泣的时刻或时间几乎变得令人愉快。我的意思是，说这话很奇怪，
but it was almost pleasant because it wasn't something that I had to make go away that I was layering all this judgment on, but rather it was something that we shared. and I thought, well, he's comfortable showing his distress to me. And it sort of was an experience that we share together and part of the richness of our relationship in a way rather than something to try and avoid. So you went on to conduct research on the effects of practicing emotional acceptance. Can you tell me what effect this has on our moods when we do it, Iris? Yes. So people differ in the degree to which they tend to accept their negative emotions. to accept their negative emotions. So some people naturally do something that I had a hard time doing. They encounter negative emotions and they don't judge them as good or bad.
但它几乎是愉快的，因为它不是那种我必须让它消失的东西，我也没有对它层层加码评判，而是我们共同经历的东西。我想，嗯，他很乐意向我展示他的痛苦。在某种程度上，这是一种我们共同经历的体验，是我们关系丰富性的一部分，而不是试图去避免的东西。所以你接着研究了练习情绪接纳的效果。你能告诉我当我们这样做时，这对我们的情绪有什么影响吗？是的。所以人们在倾向于接纳自己负面情绪的程度上有所不同。倾向于接纳自己负面情绪的程度上有所不同。所以有些人自然而然地做了一件我很难做到的事。他们遇到了负面情绪，并没有把它们评判为好或坏。
Other people have a tendency to do what I did, which is tell themselves, I shouldn't be feeling the way I'm feeling. This is wrong. And what we found is that the less people accept their negative emotions, the more the pressive symptoms, the more anxiety symptoms they experience, and the less well-being they have. And this, by the way, tends to be true for men and for women across different ethnic groups. And in that same study, we also wanted to find out why that is. And we tackled that question in two ways. In one study, we brought people into the lab,
其他人倾向于做我做过的事，也就是对自己说：我不应该有这种感觉。这不对。我们发现，人们越是不接纳他们的负面情绪，他们经历的抑郁症状、焦虑症状就越多，他们的福祉就越少。顺便说一句，对于不同族群的男性和女性来说，这往往都是真的。在同一项研究中，我们还想找出原因。我们通过两种方式解决了这个问题。在一项研究中，我们将人们带进实验室，
and we have them, ironically, give an impromptu speech that people tend to find stressful. It's a really common anxiety. And so we measured how much negative and how much positive emotions they felt. And people who tend to have an accepting mindset responded to the stressful speech with less negative emotion. They on the whole felt a little bit less anxious and a little bit less distraught. And there was another part of the study where we gave people daily diaries. So every day for two weeks, we asked them, what was the most stressful thing that happened to you today? And what were your emotional responses to that?
让他们进行讽刺性地发表即兴演讲，而人们往往觉得这很有压力。这是一个非常普遍的焦虑源。所以我们测量了他们感受到多少负面情绪和多少积极情绪。倾向于拥有接纳心态的人对有压力的演讲反应出的负面情绪更少。他们总体上感到稍微没那么焦虑，稍微没那么心烦意乱。研究的另一部分是，我们给人们写每日日记。所以在两周里每天，我们问他们：今天发生的最有压力的事情是什么？你对它的情绪反应是什么？
How much sadness, how much distress did you feel? But also positive emotions, how much strength, how much hope, how much joy did you feel during your day's most stressful event. And what we found was that people who have a accepting mindset in their daily diaries reported feeling less negative emotions in response to the day's most stressful events. And in turn, that emotional response explained why six months later,
你感到了多少悲伤，多少痛苦？还有积极情绪，在今天最具压力事件期间，你感到了多少力量、多少希望、多少快乐？我们发现，在每日日记中拥有接纳心态的人报告说，在应对当天最具压力的事件时，他们感到的负面情绪更少。反过来，这种情绪反应解释了为什么六个月后，
those same people had better mental health. So these sort of daily emotions in response to daily adversity seem to be a really important active ingredient in that link. You know, as I'm listening to these ideas and this research, I can't help but reflect on the fact that there have been philosophical and religious and spiritual traditions going back probably many centuries
同样那些人拥有更好的心理健康。所以这些应对日常逆境的日常情绪，似乎是其中的一个非常重要的活跃成分。你知道，当我听取这些想法和这项研究时，我忍不住反思这样一个事实：可以追溯到许多个世纪前的哲学、宗教和精神传统，
around the world that have talked about the same ideas, the ideas that you should actually accept your emotions for what they are, you shouldn't get overly caught up in those emotions. Do you sometimes reflect on the fact that your work as a psychologist in the 21st century and some ways is mirroring the work of ancient scholars and sages? Yes, absolutely. So many of those ideas have precursors in world religions and philosophies. And one of the biggest representation of that idea is Buddhism of course and Buddhism is the precursor to mindfulness and acceptance is a really big part of the larger philosophy of mindfulness.
世界各地的人们都在谈论相同的观点，即你实际上应该接纳你的情绪本来的样子，你不应该过分纠缠于这些情绪中。你有时会反思这样一个事实：你作为21世纪心理学家的工作，在某些方面是在映射古代学者和智者的工作吗？是的，绝对是。许多这些想法在世界宗教和哲学中都有前驱。其中最大的代表当然是佛教，佛教是正念的前驱，而接纳是更广泛的正念哲学中非常重要的一部分。
And so there's a huge intellectual that owed to Buddhist scholars as well as Buddhist practitioners and researchers on mindfulness. You know, I'm wondering whether this idea of emotional acceptance might be especially hard to, you know, accept for Americans. Many Americans I think might associate acceptance with ideas like resignation or defeat. I'm wondering whether your participants in your studies ever report that, Iris?
所以我们对佛教学者以及正念领域的佛教实践者和研究人员有着巨大的知识债务。你知道，我在想，这种情绪接纳的想法对于美国人来说可能特别难去，你知道，去接受吗？我想许多美国人可能会将接纳与诸如顺从或失败之类的想法联系起来。我想知道你在研究中的参与者是否曾经报告过这一点，爱丽丝？
That's a great question that we are really concerned about because we wouldn't want people to accept bad unjust situations even if it helps them feel better and so in the research we also asked participants about their tendency to accept bad situations, in addition to their tendency to accept their own emotions and their own negative thoughts. And this is really important because these beneficial effects of accepting your own emotions and thoughts, were connected with better mental health while accepting bad situations was not. So it's a separate thing and accepting how you feel
这是一个非常好的问题，也是我们非常关心的，因为我们不希望人们接受糟糕、不公正的处境，即使这能让他们感觉好受一些。所以在研究中，除了倾向于接受自己的情绪和负面想法之外，我们还询问了参与者接受糟糕处境的倾向。这一点非常重要，因为接受自己的情绪和想法带来的有益效果，与更好的心理健康息息相关，而接受糟糕的处境则不然。所以这是两码事，接受你的感受
does not mean accepting and resigning yourself to bad situations. In other words, I might feel badly about something and I can accept that I'm feeling badly about something, but that doesn't necessarily mean I'm turning a blind eye to the thing that's actually making me feel bad. Yes, exactly. And I think actually it might help people in a way
并不意味着接受并逆来顺受于糟糕的处境。换句话说，我对某事感到糟糕，我可以接受我对此感到糟糕，但这并不一定意味着我对真正让我感到糟糕的事情视而不见。是的，完全正确。而且我认为实际上这在某种程度上可能会帮助人们
to address bad things in their lives because if you look your negative feelings in the eye and don't get overwhelmed by them, that might help you more effectively deal with addressing bad, unjust, stressful situations. Do people ever share the worry with you that accepting negative emotions means that those negative emotions are now going to stick around forever? I think it's a really common worry and it explains something that's a little bit of a mystery, which is, acceptance sounds really easy, right? You literally don't do anything. You have your emotions, they're there,
去解决生活中的糟糕事情，因为如果你正视你的负面情绪而不被它们淹没，这可能会帮助你更有效地处理和解决糟糕、不公正、有压力的处境。人们是否曾向你表达过这样的担忧：接受负面情绪意味着这些负面情绪现在会永远挥之不去？我认为这是一个非常普遍的担忧，它解释了一个有点神秘的现象，那就是，接受听起来真的很简单，对吧？你实际上什么都不做。你有了情绪，它们就在那里，
you don't try to control them, you don't spring into action. So it sounds incredibly easy. And yet, we have a really, really hard time doing that. Even I myself, I've seen the benefits so often, I still, my first instinct is often to Oh, bad. Make it go away quick. And I think the underlying belief is that I'm going to get overwhelmed by it. And so I need to clamp down on it quickly. So I think it's a really deeply ingrained belief that many of us have. And it explains why we don't naturally embrace acceptance. We don't do it all the time. So we've been talking about the importance of accepting feelings of unhappiness, negative emotions, but we started this conversation talking about the problem with chasing happiness.
你不会试图控制它们，你不会付诸行动。所以听起来极其简单。然而，我们却发现这样做真的非常非常难。即使是我自己，我经常看到其中的好处，但我经常产生的第一个本能仍然是：哦，太糟糕了，快让它消失。我认为其根本信念是，我会被它淹没。所以我需要迅速压制它。因此我认为这是我们许多人内心深处根深蒂固的信念。这就解释了为什么我们不会自然而然地拥抱接受，我们不会一直这样做。所以我们一直在讨论接受不快乐的感觉、负面情绪的重要性，但我们在对话开始时讨论的是追逐幸福的问题。
You mentioned earlier that having high expectations for happiness can be a prescription for disappointment. What should we do instead, Iris? I think one overall recommendation is to have an accepting mindset for both our negative and our positive emotions. Don't monitor as much, don't try to avoid, for both our negative and our positive emotions. Don't monitor as much, don't try to avoid, don't try to strive too much for something else. One way to think about this is that it kind of replaces a mindset of I need to be with a mindset of I prefer.
你刚才提到，对幸福抱有过高的期望可能会导致失望。我们该怎么做，艾瑞斯？我认为总体的建议是，对我们的负面情绪和正面情绪都抱持一种接纳的心态。不要过度监视，不要试图逃避，对我们的负面情绪和正面情绪都是如此。不要过度监视，不要试图逃避，不要试图过于拼命地追求别的东西。思考这个问题的一种方式是，它有点像用“我偏好”的心态取代了“我必须”的心态。
So I think we can still have preferences. The problems come in where we tell ourselves, I must feel a certain way or else I can't have a good life. That's I think what we need to avoid. So preferences with a light touch are good for our mental health and well-being. It's the need and the concern that we want to get away from. So if you could take this insight back to when you were setting up that birthday party for your son in a park as it's raining, what would you tell yourself in that moment, Iris? What would you advise that Iris today? I would tell myself that it's okay to prefer to have a wonderful birthday party, but that I don't need it to be the perfect birthday party, where all the kids are completely happy, 100% of the
所以我认为我们仍然可以有偏好。问题出在我们对自己说：我必须有某种感受，否则我就无法过上好生活。我认为这就是我们需要避免的。因此，带着淡淡的偏好对我们的心理健康和幸福是有好处的。我们需要摆脱的是那种强烈的需求和担忧。所以，如果能把这个见解带回到当年你在公园里为儿子办生日派对却下雨的那个时刻，艾瑞斯，你会对自己说些什么？你今天会给那时的艾瑞斯什么建议？我会对自己说，想要一个美妙的生日派对是可以理解的，但我并不需要它是一个完美的生日派对，不需要所有的孩子都完全快乐100%
time, and that my son and my life and all the important things are going to be okay, even if it's not. You know, I'm thinking about the fact, Iris, there are so many books and podcasts and blogs about how to be happier and in some ways they constitute something of a happiness industrial complex. You know, and this industry tells us that we need to work hard at being happy. And in so many ways, it sounds like you're saying we need to do exactly the opposite.
的时间，而且即使不是这样，我儿子、我的生活和所有重要的事情都会好起来的。你知道我在想什么吗，艾瑞斯，有那么多的书、播客和博客都在讨论如何变得更快乐，在某些方面它们构成了一个幸福产业综合体。你知道的，这个行业告诉我们，我们需要努力去追求幸福。在很多方面，听起来你的观点好像正好相反。
Yes, I would say that feeling joy, feeling happiness is a universal human preference. So I'm not saying we should get rid of all of those books and all of the advice, but I do think we need to fine-tune a little bit just how single mindedly we go about the pursuit, as well as how we go about that pursuit. So connecting with other people, engaging in experiences over material goods, those are things that tend to work. So I'm wondering Iris, after studying the power of acceptance, both when it comes to dealing with unhappiness as well, as when it comes to dealing with happiness, has this changed your own life?
是的，我想说，体验喜悦、体验幸福是全人类的普遍偏好。所以我并不是说我们应该扔掉所有这些书和所有的建议，但我确实认为我们需要稍微微调一下我们追求幸福的专一程度，以及我们追求幸福的方式。所以，与他人建立联系，参与体验而不是追求物质财富，这些往往是行之有效的方法。所以我在想，艾瑞斯，在研究了接纳的力量之后，无论是在应对不幸时，还是在应对幸福时，这改变了你自己的生活吗？
Do you find yourself in moments being able to tell yourself not to judge your negative or positive emotions but just to accept them? It's actually pretty difficult to do, at least for me, because the way we encounter happiness, the way we encounter positive and negative emotions is really deeply ingrained in our upbringing and in our culture. So these are deeply ingrained habits of the mind. And so even though it's literally doing nothing, not judging, not trying to control,
你发现自己在某些时刻能够告诉自己不要去评判你的负面或正面情绪，而只是接受它们吗？这其实很难做到，至少对我来说是这样，因为我们遇到幸福的方式，我们遇到正面和负面情绪的方式，在我们的成长经历和文化中是根深蒂固的。所以这些都是根深蒂固的思维习惯。因此，尽管这实际上等于什么都不做——不评判、不试图控制——
it can be really difficult for people to do it. But I absolutely try to do it. And one example where I feel like I succeed it is when I reconnected with my childhood friend after a really long time, she actually had gone through cancer and had surgery and chemotherapy. She was in recovery, but still seeing her physically, it was difficult. And there were many feelings of sadness and grief for seeing what she had to go through the toll it had taken on her body. I think I managed to stay with those feelings because I was able to see how the journey of going through cancer, it's a normal reaction,
但人们要做到这一点真的很难。但我绝对会努力去做。我觉得自己成功做到这一点的一个例子是，在过了很长时间后我重新联系上了我的童年好友，她其实经历过癌症，做过手术和化疗。她在康复中，但亲眼看到她确实很不容易。看到她所经历的一切以及这对她身体造成的伤害，我心中涌起了许多悲伤和悲痛的心情。我想我设法承受住了那些感受，因为我能够看到经历癌症的历程是一个正常的反应，
it's part of life, and what it feels like is almost like watching clouds in the sky or watching a peaceful river go by, right, Where you don't try to control the clouds, you don't try to control the water, you don't judge the clouds or the water. And by doing that, viewing your own emotions as well like a river that is just flowing by or through you, we're able to accept what it is and let it go and let it flow on. Iris Moss is a psychologist at the University of California Berkeley.
这是生活的一部分，那种感觉几乎就像是在看天上的云或看着一条平静的河流流过，对吧？你不会试图控制云朵，你不会试图控制水，你也不会去评判云朵或水。通过这样做，把你的情绪也看作是一条正在流淌或穿过你的河流，我们就能够接受现状，顺其自然，让它流走。艾瑞斯·莫斯是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家。
Iris, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was so lovely to talk with you. Thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
艾瑞斯，谢谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。和你交谈非常愉快。非常感谢你。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行编辑。
For today's Unsung Hero, we bring you a story from our sister's show, My Aunt Seng Hero. Chewy Clinton grew up on a ranch in Idaho. As a teenager, he was a typical small town kid working at a hardware store and going hunting with his friends. But he was also holding on to a secret that he felt made him different from everyone else. He was gay. He hadn't told anyone the truth, even his closest friend, a classmate named Spencer. He was my best friend in high school for a number of years. And he was just fun. We like to go to punk rock together, play video games, and he was just,
今天的无名英雄，我们为您带来一个来自我们姊妹节目《我的无名英雄》的故事。楚伊·克林顿在爱达荷州的一个牧场长大。青少年时期，他是个典型的小镇男孩，在五金店打工，和朋友们去打猎。但他也藏着一个秘密，他觉得这个秘密让他与众不同。他是同性恋。他没有把真相告诉任何人，甚至连他最要好的朋友、一个名叫斯潘塞的同班同学也没有告诉。有一段时间，他是我高中时最好的朋友。他很有趣。我们喜欢一起去听朋克摇滚，玩电子游戏，而且他……
he was good to talk to. He was fun to talk to. Yeah, he was a really wonderful guy. Spencer is my unsung hero, because he is the first person I ever came out to and it was wholly unexpected. My parents were away and it was the one and only time I ever had a party out at my place. Just tons of people had a great time and spent so many of her hanging out and he was drinking and you know having problems with his girlfriend at the time.
他很健谈。和他聊天很有趣。是的，他真的是个很棒的人。斯潘塞是我的无名英雄，因为他是我向其出柜的第一个人，而且这完全出乎意料。我父母不在家，那是唯一一次我在自己家里办派对。无数的人玩得很开心，大家一起闲逛了很久，当时他喝了酒，你知道的，他和当时的女朋友有些问题。
And he was just like frustrated and upset and he wanted to go home. Well I wouldn't let anybody go home in their cars that night who had done any drinking whatsoever. And then I was like no, no, no. Let's just go walk around a talk. I mean, walking and talking. And he was sort of unloading to me as frustrations with his relationship. And there was just a low on the conversation for a couple of miles. And it was nothing that I would ever expect.
他当时很沮丧、心烦意乱，想要回家。嗯，那天晚上任何喝了酒的人，我都不让他们开车回家。然后我说：不，不，不。我们去散步聊天吧。我是说，边走边聊。他一路上向我倾倒了他对这段感情的种种沮丧。在走了好几英里的路上，我们的对话有一段陷入了沉默。而这绝对是我从未想过的。
And plan to tell him and plan to say it even if we started walking because it was something I never thought I could say to anybody who had grown up with because it was really dangerous. It just it broke in me. It broke in me and I just said it. I said Spencer, I'm gay. I'm gay. And, there was a momentary silence. Without anything else, he just put his arm around me as we were walking. And he said,
也没打算告诉他，甚至在开始散步时也没打算说出口，因为这是我从来没想过能对任何一个与我一起长大的人说的话，因为这真的很危险。它只是在我心里崩溃了。它在我心里破防了，我直接说出来了。我说了：斯潘塞，我是同性恋。我是同性恋。然后，有那么一瞬间的沉默。什么也没说，他在我们走路时直接把胳膊搭在我肩膀上。他说：
that's okay. You're still my best friend. And I still love you. And for him to respond that way. For somebody to tell me they loved me when I told them that was unlike anything I could have ever asked for. It was like a relief valve. And I still couldn't tell most people, but it was like this constant weight that had been building on me suddenly
没关系。你仍然是我最好的朋友。我依然爱着你。他能做出这样的反应。当我告诉他我是谁时，有人对我说他们爱我，这超出了我所能要求的任何东西。这就像一个减压阀。虽然我仍然不能把这件事告诉大多数人，但那种一直积压在我身上的沉重负担突然
lived a little bit. For as long as our friendship went on, he just asked questions and nobody had, and I'd never had anybody that I could tell things to. I'd never wanted to tell anybody anything. I'd never expected anybody to ask me questions. I could never have known what it would feel like for that to have that kind of friendship. Chewie went off to college. He and Spencer slowly drifted apart as high school friends often do.
得到了释放。在我们的友谊持续的整个过程中，他只是不断提问，而从来没有人这样问过我，我也从来没有过可以倾诉心声的对象。我以前从没想过要告诉任何人任何事。我从未指望过任何人会问我问题。我以前绝不可能知道拥有那种友谊会是什么感觉。楚伊去上大学了。他和斯潘塞渐渐疏远了，就像高中朋友经常做的那样。
But he says he'll always remember the compassion that Spencer showed him. I've come out to hundreds of people since that time. In fact, I live my life in a way in which visually and personality, I would be offended if somebody didn't know I was gay. And I'm never afraid. I'm never afraid anymore I'm never afraid anymore. To say that, to anyone, because I love who I am so much. I have thought about it enough times to know that he's a part of the reason for that. Chuwi Clinton, now lives in Washington, DC.
但他表示，他永远不会忘记斯潘塞对他的同情。从那以后，我对成百上千的人出柜过。事实上，我在生活中的表现——从外表到性格——如果有人不知道我是同性恋，我反而会觉得被冒犯了。而且我再也不害怕了。我再也不害怕了，再也不害怕了。对任何人说出这句话，因为我太爱自己现在的样子了。我回想过无数次，知道这也是他的功劳之一。楚伊·克林顿现在住在华盛顿特区。
If you liked this episode, if you found it timely and valuable, please take a moment and tell a friend or colleague about Hidden Brain. Right after the episode is over, please think of one person who might enjoy our program and tell them about it. If your friend is new to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe to our show. Another way you can help us build more shows like this is to support our work. Please visit support.hiddenbrain.org to learn more. I'm Shankar Vedantan.
如果你喜欢这一集，如果你觉得它及时且有价值，请花一点时间向朋友或同事推荐《隐秘大脑》。节目刚结束时，请想一万个可能会喜欢我们节目的朋友，并把节目推荐给他们。如果你的朋友是播客新手，请教他们如何订阅我们的节目。你能帮助我们制作更多类似节目的另一种方式是支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 了解更多信息。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。